I'm joined here on the set by microsoft
research director kristen toll joining
us we had planned via Skype a very cool
thing all the way from Kenya where work
even the Internet's gotta sleep some
like eleven o'clock over there but I
want to talk to you bout what we're
going to talk about some really cool
stuff one of your colleagues in the
field in Kenya currently she's working
on an ambitious project to use computing
the catalog can preserve our planets
wildlife and it's quite fascinating in
the easiest way that I would sort of
explained sort of what's happening is
that essentially things like zebras the
stripes on their backs are like
fingerprints they're actually that
unique and that this technology is able
to help track them identify them catalog
them and all of that right absolutely in
fact if you think about the example this
morning in Harry shoot stuck where they
were had the dogs come out and they were
saying what kind of dog they were yeah
right with individual animals like
zebras are like well barcodes
essentially you can use machine learning
to not only identify what type of animal
that they are but get down to even
individual animals and be able to see
how they interact with one another be
able to track their progress through
life without having to put any kind of
heavy sensor thing right that actually
might disrupt their migration patterns
or something like that so yeah that same
technology that we were showing this
morning can be applied in the wild for
what using low-cost sensors camera traps
even fly over video drones no I'm going
to ask you some about more about the
Microsoft collaboration here but we were
going to talk to tell you about sort of
this strong citizen science aspect to
the project sure can you speak to that
at all absolutely so we don't take
photos all the time we're camera happy
and one of the things that we know is
that everybody has a camera phone even
in Africa in these emerging nations and
the thing we want to be able to do is
you know the quality of those images
isn't always necessarily the best but
but that's actually how we can track
these these animals how we can monitor
where they go in the wild how they
interact with one another is through
these types of video images or even just
simple camera phones and the way that
we're doing is we're taking machine
learning to identify the individual
animals in there but allowing people to
really sort of
dissipate in that process if they're out
in the wild they're out on a hike they
want to take an image of a particular
animal they can take a shot of it and
say this endangered species actually in
this particular location we can get the
GPS location read from the phone as well
now as I mentioned we had a little bit
of an internet issue here we're going to
talk with Tanya burger wolf associate
professor University of illinois-chicago
we actually did an interview with her
earlier we're going to take a look at
that now great hi Tanya I'm so glad that
you could be with us today can you tell
us a little bit more about your
computational ecology project yes we're
building an image-based ecological
information system this is a
computational system that will allow us
to go from images which have become the
most abundant source of data about the
natural world to scientific insights
through the pipeline of image analysis
information integration and queries
analytical queries to those data we want
to create a biodiversity of view of the
planet through the lenses of individual
cameras what outcomes were you expecting
to enable new science Wow the field
ecology field biology is limited by the
number of people that can collect data
the ability to put out sensors in often
unaccessible inaccessible environments
to capture the animals that have to be
just at the right spot at the right time
and then if we go to more animated image
data collection sources then the limit
is the ability to analyze them so by
putting together the system where we can
go from all this multitude of images to
the data extracted from that we're
hoping to enable science as much high
resolution and bigger scale from
individual to ecosystems from seconds
two lifetimes
wow that's great well would you say are
some of the really good outcomes that
you've had like the people that you've
interacted with while you've been here
besides the computational ecology group
in Cambridge I've connected with people
in computer vision here in Microsoft
Research Redmond there is all the
wonderful work on visualization from
layer scape worldwide telescope that
we're going to use fetch climate will
provide the data for the climate for the
areas for the ecological context the
system will be built on Microsoft Azure
on the cloud because it is the
information is coming from all these
various sources so it has to be sort of
aggregated on the cloud but it also the
people who are looking for that for that
information and using this information
I've distributed all over the world so
they have to access access it through
the cloud oh great so I'm glad that
Asher's played a role are there other
technologies that you've encountered
while you've been here that have
actually played a role and helped you
out in the project that you're doing
photosynth and image composite editor
are the perfect tools for us to take
this multitude of photographs and create
a picture of a population of an animal
of an encounter with a wildlife so we're
going to continue these collaborations
and continue building and expanding
these tools because in their current
capacity they actually are not quite
able to take advantage of the data that
we're going to be collecting within the
context of building the system yeah so
it's been an exchange basically we've
got to learn from you and you've got to
learn from us it's been a wonderful
exchange yeah so talk a little bit about
the future where are you going to go
from here with the project so we're
building the pilot of the prologue
project and deploying it in Kenya in
July it's exciting we're going to see
first time live in action our ideas out
in the field where the tourists are
going to take pictures of animals we're
working with an old with a old Paget on
nature preserve an impala research
center in the lake keep a conservation
area of kenya so we were going to go
there and the tourists who are taking
pictures are going to become deputy
rangers
and we we will try out our system using
those pictures to extract information
and actually get right away to head back
to the tourists and build the system for
the scientists as well and hopefully a
couple of years from now with funding we
we will have a system which is capable
of extracting information from image
data that comes from all these sources
from online albums down to the last
little drone flying over some remote
area in Namibia or anywhere else and
create the biodiversity view of the
planet from this lenses of individual
cameras that are deployed all over the
world yeah it sounds like this is a
great research project tell me a little
bit about the citizen science aspects of
it we are particularly excited about
using tourists and just accidental
photographers and incidental photography
as data providers but also data labelers
went because we need to annotate these
images to train the algorithms to
recognize species and individual animals
because in this field people are not
only willing they're excited to provide
that information they become engaged so
giving those data to through collecting
the data from learning what you can get
from those data and then become
activists in conservation and advocates
for conservation in the world because
they know what's happening they feel a
part of it they can follow through
social media we're building extensions
through social media about their zebras
the one that they saw when they were out
there and it's also great educational
tool because kids can get engaged by
looking at the images by seeing learning
about the species learning how to
identify the species in those images and
that provides data again for the
algorithms but also when you go to the
zoo
a year from now then instead of this
19th century technology where you see
the printed information about the
species you are looking at we will be
able to maybe put a screen that will
show and the zebras that you're looking
here the zoo here's what they're doing
out in the wild here's where they have
been over the last week and that to me
is incredibly exciting you have to
engage at the public that Lance yeah
that's terrific tell us about some of
your collaborators some of the external
collaborators that you're working with
on this project oh this project would
not have happened without the wonderful
collaborations of many people involved
in this but the main collaborators for
the project specifically are well
university of illinois chicago hold of
course dan rubenstein is the ecologist
from princeton university he's been
studying zebras and other equals for
many years and so it's through him that
we started working many years ago and
this idea of the system came came up and
then we're collaborating with a computer
vision expert from Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute chakram check
steward and recently have been joined by
the wild me nonprofit that tracks shark
started out by tracking pounders with
sharks and citizen science project so
Jason holmberg from wild me is our main
data architect and building the sort of
database foundation for the project and
it's happening in Kenya at the Impala
Research Center and they all pitched in
Nature Conservancy so with all those
people involved talk about some of the
challenges I mean obviously with that
many folks going working with you on the
project that's got a present a challenge
where are some of the others as well
every bit of it is challenging from
collecting data in uninst romentic power
constrained and bandwidth constrained
environments such as Kenya and it's
going to be true for every wildlife
nature preserve out there pretty much to
the DES the engineering challenges to
the computer vision research that has to
be done to build the system the
information integration deployment of
the system on the cloud visualization
the actual analytical engine to be able
to ask the collage achill questions from
those data to the aspects of citizen
science and dealing with people who are
involved in data collection and then
engagement all the way through the whole
process from data to inside and then
education and outreach that we're really
hoping will be one of the outcomes of
this so it's it's simple things like
people setting their time zone correctly
for their cameras right so we have to be
able to put a protocol in place where we
can actually collect useful information
can you tell us how you got motivated to
work in this area what was the
motivation behind you going into
computational ecology my husband he's an
ecologist and we've been together for a
long time so it is through him who that
I first heard my first questions about a
college in my first stories and my first
job in ecology as a computer scientist
but it is through motion his colleagues
through these conversations but I found
myself both excited about these
questions and quite often thinking oh
there gotta be a better way of answering
this question and so finally after many
years I decided to put my brain where my
mouth has been and start finding a
better way of answering this ecological
questions and then going to Kenya with
through the collaboration with dan
rubenstein and being in that amazing
setting either the researcher or as a in
the context of the course that Dan and I
co-teach in fuel computational ecology
and seeing students not only ourselves
working on problems that neither of them
or us would have been able to do by
ourselves in our own respective fields
and coming up with new ways of seeing
the world new ways of answering
understanding the natural world in this
stunning setting of Kenya I just find
myself thinking something that you
people get to say once in their lifetime
I'm doing exactly what I want to be
doing and this is just look and and and
an amazing opportunity
I continue to be grateful for and
continue to be excited by it well I
really want to thank you for being with
us today Tania and I really wish you
very good luck out in Kenya and with
your project in the future it sounds
like a great project that we're going to
have that will help everyone understand
computational ecology better thank you
and thank you for the only
collaborations to her fun peak back
there to conversation between tanya and
kristen kristen is here with me and we
were able to reach out and get in touch
with tanya she is on the phone she is in
Kenya we know it's very late Tanya in
fact it's almost tomorrow to you thanks
for staying up very late with us one
question we would love to ask you about
is ultimately establishing that
relationship with Microsoft talk about
how you came to work with Microsoft
there about five places in the world
hello by the way there about five places
in the world that have computational in
ecology to get them their name in the
title and Microsoft's computational
ecology research group at Cambridge UK
is one of them and so when I was looking
for a place to spend my sabbatical that
group was a very natural place for me to
be that started I indeed spend three
months there in fall 2013 last fall and
it started wonderful collaborations part
of which is this project image-based
ecological information system started
out of a collaboration also in
discussions with the group there with
Lucas jopa and withdrew purrs and then I
continued it because we want we realize
that we need to have it have a deployed
on Azure on the cloud and so azure was a
choice a natural choice for us and in
the spring I came to work with crystal
and the connections group at microsoft
Redmond research Redmond well Tonya we
know it's very late thanks for giving us
a couple of minutes to your time we want
to let you get some sleep because we
know you got zebras to track in the
morning in just a couple of hours thanks
for doing this with us we appreciate it
and keep up the great work okay thank
you thank you for the support absolutely
great stuff there a big thanks to You
Kristen as well for eating the charged
doing the heavy lift and you interviewed
her I just hit play no forget it